hey youtubers its charlie
this week on the walking dead we learned
the freakin governor is back and he's
probably been perving on the prison the
whole time the worst of the flu is over
Tyreese still doesn't know about Carroll
and every Wednesday will now be
spaghetti Tuesday's so let's talk about
our favorite moments and then I'll do my
review so first things first the freakin
governor what has he been doing this
whole time the teaser for the next
episode kind of makes it seem like he's
been perving on the prison the whole
time just camping out in the woods
nearby maybe he's even the one that was
putting all the rats in the fence he's
been gone for several episodes but I got
some behind-the-scenes info that
explains why he hasn't been on till now
I'll talk about that right after my
review number 2 the flu is almost over
the episode kind of implied that the flu
is over but I think that people will
still be recovering in the next episode
and they'll be recovering emotionally a
lot of this episode was about not losing
hope Rick and Hershel we're talking
about how things will never be the same
again and obviously people are gonna
start breaking down just because of all
the constant threats how crazy was that
when Hershel saw that Glenn was starting
to lose it and turned and the camera
just pointed right at that Walker with a
bag on his face and you just thought oh
I know exactly what's gonna happen do
you think you would have had the courage
to fight the Walker for that air bag to
save Glenn of course we all would Glenn
is one of our favorite characters next
up Carl is totally turning into a badass
you even saw Rick kind of smile at him
while they were stabbing Walker's in the
face I think he's still trying to see
him as his little kid but Carl is really
starting to turn into more of a fighter
now I'm really hoping that that Carl
fighter storyline will actually dub tail
with the governor storyline wouldn't it
be awesome to see Carl take out the
governor obviously Michonne is the one
that should do it but Carl doing it
would just be so much crazier and can we
talk about Tyreese Tyreese obviously
still does not know about Carol but it
was really interesting watching Rick
start telling people obviously Maggie
kind of had her doubts at first but that
she said no you did the right thing and
then after that none of the other
characters question Rick's decision I
think they all kind of understood the
Carol had to leave what is going to
happen when Tyreese finds out he's
obviously probably going to lose it
again he's mostly concerned with Sasha
right now but I imagine his reaction
will be similar to the way that other
people react when they find out that the
governor's back so the big questions
after this episode are one what has he
been doing this whole time has he just
been camping out on the woods being a
total perv and two how are people going
to continue dealing with all these
constant threats obviously we have the
flu now we have the governor and there's
the constant threat of the walkers so
people
starting to break down emotionally the
next episode is called too far-gone
and kind of deals with that theme be
sure to subscribe to get my video I'll
post it right up to the episode airs but
what did I think of the episode overall
I give it a solid b-plus it was so
intense despite being so self contained
in this small cell block a the episode
was called internment so we knew it was
basically going to be focused on the
small group of characters that we're
just gonna slowly degenerate into
walkers obviously Herschel's big theme
was keeping hope alive but the minute we
saw people start to turn you knew it was
just gonna jump off a cliff and go crazy
raise your hand if you thought that
Lizzie was actually gonna stab that
Walker in Glens cell in the head I could
have never predicted that she was going
to treat it like a dog and try to lead
it away here boy here boy it was so
amazing but just like that intense theme
song that The Walking Dead has at the
beginning of the episode that final
teaser made me so excited for next
week's episode I mean it's just like the
governor was gonna turn around and weak
at us you just see me shown now just
sharpening her sword in her cell almost
like she has governor radar now be sure
to let me know what your favorite
moments were in the comments below and
let me know what do you think the
governor has been doing this whole time
outside of the prison the teaser for the
next episode kind of implies that he's
been in the woods the whole time but we
still have no idea what he's going to be
doing although there were a lot of
explosions behind him in the teaser for
next episode so clearly he's going to be
blowing a ton of up but those are
you wondering what we haven't seen the
governor till now Scott Gimple said they
basically just got sick of using the
character season 3 was all about the
governor and they didn't want to just
keep using him and makes his enforce
seem like season 3 part 2 and something
else you can get really excited for
Andrew Lincoln said that Rick is going
to develop a new way to kill walkers
this season he didn't say what it is but
I'm imagining it has something to do
with like a cattle shoot if you've ever
seen a slaughterhouse they basically
funnel cattle through this really narrow
opening so they can kill them one at a
time and you know in this episode how
rick was basically walking through that
fenced in area i have a feeling they're
gonna set up something like a walker
shoot so they can just all kill them one
at a time but let me know what your
theories are in addition to all my
regular videos i'm posting three new
Doctor Who videos as part of my
countdown to the 50th anniversary I'll
also be posting information on my next
Doctor Who giveaway I'll probably say
that video on Friday because I'll be
giving away DVDs for the 50th
anniversary right now click here to
learn more about Walking Dead this
season and you can click here to learn
all about my videos for the 50th
anniversary I'm making a lot of special
content in partnership with Nerdist and
the BBC so it's gonna be really cool
thank you so much for watching
high-five see you guys tomorrow
you